You know what kind of person I am?
Exactly.
So if you text, email, or tell me
"Hey let's hang out soon."
I'm gonna follow up with
Sure!  I can do Tuesday morning or Thursday night.
Hello?
(gasps) Did you just block me?
Let's get one thing straight: if you say
"Let's hang out soon!"
or "We should catch up!"
You better be damn ready for me to follow up
with some specific dates, times, and location ideas
because I follow up, motherfucker.
So if you don't want to hang out, don't suggest it.
I don't suggest things I have no intention of doing.
I'm gonna murder you.
Mom!
Oh no, calm down.  I'm just saying a bunch of shit that I have no intention of following through on.
As pathetic as it sounds, I've had quite a few people tell me
"We should catch up" and then just never respond when I offer up times we can actually hang out.
And I feel stupid.  I feel like I'm being rejected even though I didn't put myself out there.
Hey!  Uhm, would you like to go on a date sometime?
Sure!  Uhm, I can do Friday.
No.
Okay, how about Saturday?
I could do Sunday.
Oh my God, I don't want to go on a date with you.  Could you get the hint already!?
And the solution is easy: don't say what you don't mean.
Ta da!
Because there is no reason to.
If you really need an alternative say "see you later"
or "talk to you soon."  At least those are vague enough
that I could just respond with an emoji, and then move on with my life
without feeling utterly rejected for no reason.
(sighs)
I wonder if the people this video is about are going to see this.
I hope so.
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.
I'd like to say thank you to SquareSpace for sponsoring today's video.
You can go to Squarespace.com and start building your website today.
Oh!  It looks professionally designed regardless of your skill level and there's absolutely no coding required!
Oh!  Ok, still here.
The tools are all intuitive and easy to use and if you sign up for a year, you get a free domain.
Start your free trial today at Squarespace.com.
And don't forget to use the offer code "Anna" for 10% off at checkout.
No?  Ok.
Squarespace.  You should.
I'm not getting out of this one.
You know what I love?  Being productive.
Being productive isn't hard.  It just takes a little thought.
So first off, if you don't have a Life Map for 2016, make that right now.
This is your big picture.  It's your goals and your dreams and everything you hope to accomplish in the new year.
Next, you're going to break down  each of those things into executable actions.
I do this with all of my big productions--it's where you list each